good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video comes to you in for very special
parts each beginning with the letter P
part 1 peeps part 2 prom part 3 put
photographs and part 4 puppy comma
bubbles the nerdfighting Hank yesterday
I was supposed to eat somewhere in the
neighborhood of 315 peeps you'll never
guess how many peeps I actually ate none
the thing is Hank it's kind of a crazy
busy week because I got to turn around
these two revisions one on this book I'm
writing and then one on this movie and I
figured it would likely be kind of
disastrous to my productivity if I ate
more than 300 peeps in a single day
which turned out to be one of those
instances where procrastination is
awesome because a group of nerdfighters
banded together and ate more than 200
peeps on my behalf link in the sidebar
so now I only have to eat like 102 peeps
in a day I haven't figured out the exact
number yet but it's somewhere like
slightly above a hundred but below fatal
thank you thank you thank you to the
nerdfighters who ate peeps on my behalf
this Sunday I'm going to eat the
remaining peeps and then I'll make a
video about it and it will be funny and
you'll laugh at my pain I mean seriously
Hank sometimes I think that if it
weren't for schadenfreude there would be
no Freud at all part to prom
Hank ktw writes I'm a senior in high
school in a dedicated nerdfighter and
there's this boy I'd really like to ask
to prom his name is miles and you're one
of his favorite authors Katy I am here
to help
oh boy I'm nervous I haven't asked
someone to prom since I asked someone to
prom what if his mom answers that's
going to be weird how am I going to
explain myself her boy feeling the
tension guys it's miles five miles it's
John Green calling I'm the author of the
novels Looking for Alaska and buness
Katherine's in Paper Towns okay I just
have a quick question two quick
questions for you first is there a young
woman who is with you named Katie will
you go to prom with her happily no thank
you thanks for being awesome and have a
great time problem and please send us
pictures all right take care
yay that went much better than the last
time I asked
to prom part three put photographs hey
name master Tom has done such a great
job of finding awesome pictures on the I
could have just called it part three
pictures doofus but anyway Thomas done
such a good job with finding pictures on
the ning that i wanted to share some of
them with you
hank i'm always encouraged when I see
people in comments asking what dftba
means because that means we're
recruiting by the way nerdfighters other
than don't forget to be awesome what
could dftba mean leave your answers in
the comments secondly cake Hank I don't
know if that's real but it sure looks
awesome third I just want to point out
over on the left of this work of art me
licking a cat then we have maybe the
most amazing nerdfighter shoes I've ever
seen in my life followed by maybe the
seen in my life what is it with you
people and shoes you're brilliant with
them Hank here's another awesome cake my
favorite thing about this cake is that
we're the actual cover of Looking for
Alaska says a novel this one says a cake
and finally nerdfighter Rob from
Cornwell titled this photograph do not
tread on the green pressure pad or you
will be shot with a laser in your head
will come off nerdfighters if you want
to see your amazingly nerd fight a stick
photographs featured if the ning upload
your pictures to your profile link in
the sidebar
i mean not a link to your particular
profile in the sidebar but sort of a
link to the general nerdfighter ning in
the sidebar part for puffy am i just
like an overly proud dog parent or is
the way willy sits kind of adorably cat
like hank will see you singing tomorrow
for now Willy says best wishes